Il est là !
Je le vois!
Attrapons-le!
Le niveau de la mer monte tellement vite que
les gens doivent quitter leur maison
pour vivre dans les terres. C'est ça qui me choque !
On sait pas qui sont réellement les gens
qui nous gouvernent.
On nous cache beaucoup de choses.
C’est la pénurie mondiale d’énergie
alors on est obligés de se limiter.
Avant, y’avait une forêt pas loin de Montauban,
on disait qu’il y avait des fées et des korrigans
Maintenant, c’est des immeubles
Ma maison est construite avec des déchets,
ça recycle !
On sait pas ce qu’on mange, de toute façon
y’a plus d’agriculture en Bretagne
Au collège, on doit pédaler pour produire
de l’électricité.
Pourtant, il y a des panneaux
solaires sur le toit et des éoliennes dans la cour
On doit pédaler même la nuit, on se relaie
Y’a des caméras de surveillance dans les
couloirs et le principal nous donne des ordres par un haut-parleur
Quand on a une interro, on porte un casque
qui permet de récupérer l’énergie quand on réfléchit beaucoup
On vient de St Malo toutes les trois.
On a migré à Montauban avec nos familles
à cause de la montée des eaux
Au fur et à mesure des années, on voyait
que l’eau montait.
L’année dernière, notre
collège a fermé car il était inondé
Franchement, ne venez pas vous promener à St Malo
Les 4èmes F prenez la relève en salle dynamo ! Immédiatement !
J’en ai marre de pédaler !
Qu’est-ce qu’ils en font de toute cette
électricité ?
Tu trouves pas qu’elle est bizarre la voix du principal ?
C’est vrai ça
Pfu, c'est vraiment pas bon
Du temps de mes grands-parents, ils mangeaient
du pain, du poisson, des fruits...
J'aurais trop aimé connaître cette époque !
Moi j'aime bien
Hé pas touche !
J'ai soif
Un verre d'eau par personne, c'est la règle
du rationnement
Ça va Maxens ? T'es tout bizarre aujourd'hui...
Ben, j'ai découvert que...
Venez, je préfère vous dire ça dehors
Bah dis donc, vous êtes vraiment pas dans vos assiettes aujourd'hui.
Je vais chercher un balai
Regardez, y'a une porte cachée ! Elle est
fermée avec un code
Je m'en occupe
Finalement je vais passer le balais
Regardez, c'est des photos ! « archives 2019 » ça date !
Elisa, t'es sur la photo !
Mais non, c'est ma grand-mère !
Elle est pas mal...
Vas-y, fais voir ! Pouah ! Ah ! Ah !
Attention, voilà le surveillant !
T’écoutes quoi ?
“Orelsan”, un truc que ma grand-mère
écoutait quand elle était jeune
Je peux écouter ?
C’est trop bien !
il y a 100 fois plus de déchets que d’humains, Basique
Les bouteilles d’eau tuent les poissons, Simple
Gilets jaunes ou pas, qu’est-ce que ça
change, le monde se détruit, Basique
Dites aux tortues que les sacs en plastique
ne sont pas des méduses, Simple
Fumer te détruit, mais tu détruis la planète
en jetant tes mégots par terre, Basique
Plus tard, il y aura plus d’immigration
que de maisons, Simple
Ce n’est pas parce que nous ne connaissons
pas les ours polaires qu’on doit leur faire du mal, Basique
La pollution tue la nation, Simple
Si tu dis que tu ne pollues jamais, c’est
que tu pollues souvent, Simple
Les substances illicites se répartisses partout dans le monde, ça tue la nation, Basique
S’il y a trop de voitures, on va tous tousser, Basique
Ce sont souvent ceux qui plantent des arbres qui en coupent le plus, Simple
La pollution avance vite, qu’elle va finir
par se faire flasher, Basique
Quand on parle de l’immigration, j’ai
pas d’idée, Simple
Si nous gâchions, c’est que nous nous rendions pas compte, Basique
Dans le futur, les déchets domineront le
monde, Simple
Si la forêt amazonienne est détruite, c’est
qu’il y a une déforestation, Basique
Vous dites que vous êtes intelligent, mais
vous avez signé la perte de notre Univers. Simple.
Un jour la planète prendra sa revanche, Basique
La statue de la Liberté devrait apprendre
à nager, Simple
Le réchauffement nous tue mais on ne le vois pas, Basique
Les personnes qui se plaignent sont souvent celles qui ne font rien, Simple
Vous n’avez pas les bases
J'aime pas l'histoire !
Moi non plus
Moi j'aime bien
Vous m'avez crue ? Ah Ah !
Oh tous les cinq ça suffit, je veux vous voir à la fin de l'heure
Vous savez quoi ? Il paraît qu'il y a une
porte secrète dans la cantine
Non !
Ce collège est trop bizarre. On devrait faire parler les profs !
Venez par là s'il vous plait. Il faut que je vous parle
Puisque c'est comme ça je vais vous coller à tous les cinq un zéro pointé !
Non ! Ça va baisser ma moyenne
Moi je m'en fiche, je suis habituée !
Ah ! Mes élèves préférés !
Oh non, c'est pas possible ce que tu dis quand même !
Aller viens prendre un café
ça suffit arrêtez ça !
Qu'est-ce qui se trame dans ce collège ?
Vous nous cachez des choses !
Qui est le principal ?
Arrêtez ça on vous a dit !
Vous devriez parler
Nous avons des informations sur vous
Quelles informations ?
Tous les mardis, au bistrot, à 18h exactement
Ah bon ?
Nous allons voir ça avec le principal !
Vous ne vous en tirerez pas comme ça !
Qui est le principal ?
Nous allons faire un rapport !
Vous voulez pas suivre les profs ? Nous, on
doit aller pédaler
Qu'est-ce qui se passe ?
Ils nous cachent des choses.
OK, on fonce.
Regardez, ils entrent dans la salle des profs
C’est bizarre.
Ouai ! C’est quoi tout ces fils ?
Les...les...les profs c’est des robots!
Genre ! Les profs c’est des androïdes déguisés en humains
Madame Pleumeleuc ?!
On dirait qu’elle se met en pause.
C’est un truc de dingue, c’est un truc
de dingue !
Bidibidi, c’est l’heure du contrôle d’espagnol
T’es sérieux là? on va se faire remarquer !
Vite cachez-vous, j’entends du bruit !
Regardez M Wender et M Bosseur sont en train de se brancher sur le secteur !
Dire que Mme Pleumeleuc c’est un robot.
Faut qu’on file et qu’on en parle aux
autres.
Hé ! Vous avez pas l’impression qu’on
est des agents secrets?
Ouais!!!!!!!
Allez, on file!
Eh ! Vous trouvez pas bizarre la voix du directeur dans les hauts-parleurs ?
Pourquoi ils nous font pédaler tout le temps, à quoi ça sert ?
Je suis sûre que les profs nous cachent des choses
Les profs, c’est des robots !
On a trouvé une porte cachée avec un code
dans la cantine !
Bon on fait quoi maintenant ?
Je peut récupérer des
infos dans la salle d’ordinateur
Je la clé justement !
Nous, on va déclencher l’alarme incendie comme ça le bâtiment il sera évacué on pourra explorer tranquillement
Bon, comment on fait pour déclencher l’alarme à incendie?
Le surveillant, il arrête pas de nous regarder !
Tu proposes quoi?
Oh je sais, j'ai qu'à aller parler au surveillant et lui demander de m’aider pour mon exercice de maths.
Bonne idée ! Comme ça, ça fera diversion
et Lucas et Mathis pourront s'éclipser en cachette.
Super, moi je fais le guet
Monsieur, excusez moi, est-ce que vous pouvez m'aider pour l'exercice de maths je comprends pas…
Chut ! Faites moins de bruit. On va se faire prendre !
C’est trop chaud, je vais demander de l'aide aussi
C’est bon, j’ai la clé !
On dirait mission impossible
C’est clair !
Moi je reste ici pour faire le guet, j'ai vu le responsable technique, il est pas loin, ok ?
D'accord
Regardez, les profs c'est des robots, apparement c'est un nouveau modèle, ils ont été créés cette année.
C’est bizarre, y a aucune information sur
le principal
Si, attends je clique
Voilà le principal !
Euh non, je crois c’est le président des Etats-Unis il y a 50 ans a peu près
Alors ça doit être son petit-fils
Regardez, c’est un plan du collège
avec des passages secrets dans les murs.
J’imprime !
Grouillez! Il arrive !
Attends, la feuille ne veut pas sortir de
l’imprimante.
Si c'est bon, ça y est !
Vite, allez on se dépêche !
Alerte intrusion ! alerte intrusion !
Je force l’arrêt de l’ordinateur
Non, attends, appuie sur alt F4
Laissez tomber ! Allez on s’en va !
Regardez !
les 3e qui ont disparu, ils sont enfermés
pour fabriquer de la nourriture !
Hé ! C’est nos déchets qui sont recyclés en
nourriture !
Attendez, regardez, c’est la porte qui mène sur le cagibi de la cantine !
Regardez !
Là, voilà la machine à fabriquer les profs !
Ca ne peut plus durer !
Moi, je ne veux pas de robots comme professeurs
Il se servent de nous pour faire fonctionner
leurs machines
La pénurie d’énergie c’est pas de notre
faute, ils ont pas à nous le faire payer !
STOP !!!!!!!!!!!
Madame la Présidente
Mesdames & messieurs, il y a 10 ans, les élèves
du collège Evariste Galois de Montauban de
Bretagne se sont rebellés.
J’en faisais d’ailleurs partie.
Cette rébellion s’est répandue dans tous
les collèges du pays puis dans tous les collèges du monde.
Et désormais, les professeurs-robots sont
interdits et les élèves ne sont plus forcés
de produire de l’électricité.
Suite à cela, nous avons trouvé une nouvelle
source d’énergie inépuisable par les plantes.
Les peuples de tous les pays ont replanté
des arbres, l’effet de serre a diminué
et nous vivons actuellement un refroidissement
climatique.
J’ai la joie de vous apprendre que nous
avons retrouvé l’ équilibre naturel
Merci à tous